I've always been skeptical of the notion
that the liberal media are full of pedos
until I saw the Mad vitriol with which
the media have been attacking Jim
caviezel's new movie about child sex
trafficking the sound of freedom
this film is being marketed to either
specific Q Anon Believers or to people
who believe all of the same tenets as Q
Anon but claim they don't know what it
is
and the sound of Freedom does focus on a
real issue of sex trafficking but that
theme it's sort of like that kernel of
truth that feeds the Q Anon conspiracy
theory tell us how those two things work
together
sure and the most durable and the most
believable conspiracy theories are not
entirely false there's something in them
that is true and the rest of it is false
but the Believers point to the one true
thing and they say oh you don't believe
that this particular thing is true in
terms of child trafficking we know
trafficking is real we know it has real
victims no one is denying that but these
films are created out of moral panics
they're created out of bogus statistics
they're created out of fear and with
something like sound of Freedom it
specifically is looking at keyword on
concepts of these child trafficking
rings that are run by the high-level
Elites the Q Anon Q Anon Q Anon the libs
are Furious the movie hit over 18
million dollars in its box office
opening six days ago it's already
grossed over 40 million within a week it
is a certified hit so desperate to
convince people to stop seeing it the
media are now trying to link the movie
to Q Anon Washington Post quote sound of
freedom is a box office hit whose star
races Q Anon the guardian sound of
Freedom the Q Anon adjacent Thriller
seducing America and rolling stone sound
of freedom is a superhero movie for dads
with brain worms the Q a non-tinged
thriller about child trafficking is
designed to appeal to the conscience of
a conspiracy adult Boomer now I don't
know much about Q Anon the only people I
ever hear really talk about Q Anon are
the liberal media I run in lots of
conservative circles all over the
country I don't hear about it I turn on
CNN for five seconds it's all they talk
about
but what's really strange about this
coverage
is that the movie is based on a true
story it's the story of how a real guy
Tim Ballard rescued kids from sex
trafficking
so the libs are saying that a true story
an indisputably true story is q a
non-adjacent
which means some people really do
believe in Q Anon
the liberal media who spent the whole
weekend inadvertently insisting that the
theory is true right now text Knowles
Canada wlas to 98 98 98 as central banks
in countries such as China India and
Australia begin looking to transition to
a digital currency the Federal Reserve
has been contemplating the same for the
U.S with a digital currency the
government could track every single
purchase you make officials could even
prohibit you from purchasing certain
products officials could easily freeze
or seize part or all of your money Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold you can do that with the help of
Birch gold they are who I get my gold
from so do thousands of other concern
Savers Birch gold will help you convert
an existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in
Gold you don't pay a penny out of pocket
when currencies fail gold is a safe
haven how much more time does the Dollar
have protect your savings with gold
Birch gold has an A plus rating with
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text Knowles Canada 98
98 98 get your free info kit on gold if
a central bank digital currency becomes
a reality it will be nice to have some
gold to depend upon text Knowles Canada
wlas to 98 98.98 right now go to
helixsleep.com Knowles with everything
going on in the world right now you
could really use a good night's sleep
that is why you got to check out Helix
mattress he likes his harnessed years of
extensive mattress expertise to bring
their customers a truly elevated sleep
experience they just launched their new
Helix Elite the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for about three years now I
absolutely adore this bed night after
night I sleep like a sweet little baby I
want the same for you Helix has a sleep
quiz that matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress that was made for someone else
why do you want to get into my mattress
huh I'm a married guy you need to get
your own mattress go to helixsleep.com
Knowles take their two-minute sleep quiz
to find the perfect mattress for your
body and sleep tight their flexible
payment plans make it so that a great
night's sleep is never far away Helix is
offering 20 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for my listeners hurry
on over to helixsleep.com Knowles with
Helix better sleep starts
now they're saying it's all a crazy
conspiracy theory
it's the Q Anon about which I know
pretty much nothing
from what I can tell is this crazy
conspiracy theory that there is an elite
pedophile ring that involves some of the
wealthiest and most influential people
in the world
and just
apropos of nothing uh here is an
interview that has recently come out
from one of Jeffrey Epstein's victims
I have uh spent the last 17 years in my
own personal
prison for what year Jeffrey and all the
co-conspirators did to me I was raped
repeatedly I was raped three times a day
sometimes
and I was not the only girl on that
island there was a constant stream of
girls being raped over and over and over
again and yes Guillain must die in
prison because I've been in hell and
back for the last 17 years
seven for me I was 10 years old when Liz
Stein was being trafficked I was 10.
that is how long the sex trafficking
ring has been going on for
what is the claim of the liberal media
here
they just slapped this label Q Anon Q
Anon whatever that is the thing that
you've only ever heard about from the
liberal media
but what are they actually saying
they're
denying the existence of sex trafficking
no you heard the CNN lady admit no sex
driving is a real problem are they not
denying the existence of elite sex
trafficking Rings they probably are
because the liberal media tried to kill
the Jeffrey Epstein story but we know
the Jeffrey Epstein story is real we
know that Jeffrey Epstein was paling
around with the most powerful people on
Earth Prime Ministers presidents
royalty major financiers heads of
Industry we know that he had his own
James Bond villain-esque private island
in the Caribbean where he was bringing
an endless slew of young girls he was
partnering with with major modeling
head honchos and bringing these young
girls through the island to engage in
weird sex stuff with the most
influential people in the world so then
then we know that Jeffrey Epstein was
arrested and mysteriously killed himself
after multiple cameras malfunctioned and
multiple jail employees just forgot to
do their job or fell asleep on the job
what's the conspiracy theory
I don't here's the here's the only
conspiracy that that
we haven't really solved yet all of it
is so far in the open the question is
who's in Jeffrey Epstein's black book
isn't that kind of weird isn't it weird
that we started to prosecute Jeffrey
Epstein we did prosecute Elaine Maxwell
and we still don't know who his clients
were
don't expect to hear about that on the
the liberal media we're not even talking
about a regular sex trafficking ring
like you see in the sound of Freedom
movie which is a very good movie by the
way I watched the movie in an advanced
screener it's very good I'm not
surprised that it's doing huge box
office numbers not surprised that the
libs hate it so much
but I'm no I guess I am surprised that
they hated so I'm not surprised that
they hate it I'm surprised they hate it
so much I'm surprised that they are
willing to show their hand this much
that they're not only willing to to
cover for Jeffrey Epstein and downplay
that story and kill that story when
different reporters wanted to to bring
it to public attention but now they're
trying to downplay the existence of sex
trafficking entirely
they say oh that's Q Anon that's Q Anon
maybe maybe everything that people have
said about the liberal media maybe it's
right boy what a great clip that was
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel don't miss a single clip or vid
or interview or game or anything see you
next time